what about uh you know the spin-off I
think we talked about it maybe did we
talk about it before
probably briefly because it was briefly
you know they were it was called Green
Arrow and the in The Cranberries no in
the canaries and the canaries and uh it
was a spin-off of Arrow and it didn't go
now this seems odd to me because it
seems like Everything You Touch goes
works all right now everything but how
do you deal with rejection how do you
deal with that were you just kind of
like or was that kind of a was that a
sting that it hurt
that was hard you know again because
it's Mia and it's a character that I
love so much and and you know we all
worked so hard on that pilot and it's
that was such a
you know it was such a journey we all
say that but it was in between crisis on
infinite Earths and the series finale of
Arrow we shot a backdoor pilot for this
spin-off and somehow our crew was so
incredible and they pulled it together
and the writers and everyone was
stretched so thin and made a pilot that
was great and people really seemed to
love it and we loved it and it was very
well received but it's just one of those
things that you have to trust in the
universe that if it's meant to be yours
it will be and if it's not there's
something else out there for you and
I feel I mean as much as I would have
loved to do that show and and I still
would love to continue Mia's Journey
moving forward the fact that I that Mia
still exists in the world and I have a
new story to tell with a new character
that is equally as
challenging and interesting and and
complex
it's really exciting yeah I can't
complain no did they let you see the
pilot
I've seen bits of it really so what
aren't you curious that you want to see
the whole thing
I do want to see it watching myself
isn't my favorite thing really wait a
minute no I didn't know that
yeah you don't like watching yourself
I don't I don't love it I like it for
the learning experience of it you know I
I I can enjoy it for the story but I I
always want to I always think there's
room to to improve and to learn from
things you've done and and there's ways
that you can keep pushing yourself to be
better and you know being the Perpetual
student that I am I tend to see those
things more than other things at times
um but this is part of it and I've made
my piece with it you know I've been
doing this for years now I've made my
piece of the fact that yeah that's not
the most comfortable thing for me but I
would rather be a little bit
uncomfortable and get to enjoy
everyone's work and what we put so hard
in and in celebrating that together then
avoid it entirely just because of
something in my head